Russell Westbrook is one of my favorite
players to watch and I think he's also
one of the more misunderstood players in
this league you know him very well
you've known him for a very long time
what do people have wrong about Russ
that Russ is a winner honestly Russ
brings a winning culture um Russ plays
hard Russ is a great teammate great
locker room guy I think that's what
people don't get to see cuz you're
you're not with Russ on a day-to-day
basis what you see from Russ is him
being on the court um and him in games
like you don't see what he he brings the
value that he brings to a team um and
being on the same team with him for
multiple years now um is the reason why
I wanted to bring him over with us uh
with the Clippers is I just saw it from
afar joining that Oklahoma team being an
outside looking in just the way he
connected with everybody was was
inspiring like it brought out the best
of everybody and um you know I I thought
we could have used that um in our
locking room um and and you need a
leader at the point guard position mhm